today I'm campaign check we're looking
at the NHS and claims like this one the
content of those documents tells us that
the NHS is on the table in future trade
talks it tells us that there are you
know huge interests looking at all
different aspects of our NHS and it
cannot be right that we don't take these
documents very very seriously so is the
NHS really on the table in Britain's
trade talks with America law rapid cook
they're talking about leaks papers from
initial trade discussions but is there a
smoking gun in there well there's more
than 400 pages of this stuff you can see
Jeremy Corbyn there with it but when he
goes through it the short answer is no
not really the NHS doesn't seem to be on
the table at all there's no discussion
about hospitals being sold off or ending
up in American hands but there is some
evidence for the documents about
American negotiators pushing to change
terms on pharmaceuticals in part use
what they describe as angst on American
steam consumers they say they're paying
too much for drugs so there's a section
for instance that says the Americans
pushed hard on changing the term terms
of patents aiming to extend them which
could me in the UK spending more on
branded rather than cheaper generic
drugs and that's an issue because as
this chart shows you Britain is far more
reliant on generic drugs like those are
the cheap ones whose payments have
expired than almost any other country in
the developed world then it give you an
example of why that matters last year
the patents on a drug called humor it's
used to treat a number of conditions
including rheumatoid arthritis it
expired and NHS boss Simon Stephens he
said that that's going to save 300
million pounds a year another example he
said of how the smarter approach in the
UK and Europe gives patients a much
better deal than they get in the United
States so any attempt to change patent
rules could have an impact and Labour
say that this American push on
pharmaceuticals means drugs in this
country could get far more expensive why
cuz if you take a closer look at this
chart you can see that Americans spend
more than two and a half times what
Britons spend on pharmaceuticals labour
says that means drugs here could get
two-and-a-half times more expensive
which equates to 500 million pounds a
week but I'd be a bit cautious about
that number aside from anything else one
of the reasons Americans spend more on
drugs is that they take more than
they've got more prescriptions over
there and finally it's worth saying this
wouldn't be the first time Americans
have pushed hard on pharmaceuticals in a
trade deal they also try to do so in
deals with
South Korea and Australia as well but
those countries push back with quite a
lot of success this is a deeply
complicated area the trade talks haven't
even started yet
the NHS doesn't seem to be on the table
pharmaceutical pricing might be but
whether it has a knock-on consequence
for what we all pay remains to be seen